[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning the
governor of louisiana is making an
urgent new appeal for people in his
state to get vaccinated pointing to what
he calls an astronomical his word rise
in covet cases since june the number of
deaths in louisiana has more than
tripled 300 percent increase now our
david begneau takes us inside one icu at
a lafayette hospital to show us how
healthcare workers are fighting two
battles there's the pandemic and also
the spread of misinformation
24 years old
this is kaylee rayo she is one of the
sickest coveted patients inside of the
main icu here at our lady of lourdes
regional medical center in lafayette
louisiana
her mother is amy we let our guard down
we started
venturing out we booked a family
vacation
we thought like the rest of the world
this isn't that real of a virus
it didn't attack our family but it did
when the rayo family returned home from
vacation everyone in this photo tested
positive for covid
all of them were unvaccinated and all of
them recovered from the virus except for
kaylie who was eight months pregnant at
the time she says i'm very very weak and
she had two purple
circles bigger than silver dollar bills
on her cheeks
that was eight days after she was
diagnosed with covid her mother rushed
her to the emergency room doctors
delivered her baby crew and five days
later kaylee was placed on a ventilator
so kaylee's doing okay i don't think
that she's
a whole lot better certainly she's not
worse that was the update that kaylee's
mother received from dr frank cormier
just from me personally okay i just want
you to know
thank you
you said thank you
but something about the way you said
thank you to me sounded personal to you
yeah it's personal i know she's mom it
doesn't want a loser but i sure don't
want to either
what's going through your head i'm
scared for her i don't want her to go
through this
i hope we can pull her through i just
we're just not in a phase yet where we
know first she will make it yet or not
every one of the 24 patients in the main
icu here are coveted positive
has a single disease
ever filled every icu bed in here never
in my lifetime
jennifer mouton has been an icu nurse
for 37 years we've been called murderers
we don't know what we're doing i'm on
social media the other day and
somebody's educating me on what we
should be doing to treat our patients
he was the manager of mattress gallery
and i thought well you know everybody
needs mattresses uh i support what you
do
but in turn i expect the same kind of
respect amen
[Music]
welcome to lafayette
born and raised one of the beauties of
south louisiana is how people rally
together to help each other after
hurricanes or floods
but in this pandemic with only about 40
percent of this area fully vaccinated
there's fighting and division and hatred
if people could come and spend the day
with me i can assure you they'd be
running they get vaccinated but social
media in this area is filled with lies
and misinformation about the virus and
the vaccine there's another part of me
that doesn't understand how the public
can so easily believe
random people on social media who have
no medical background shannon ivey is a
covet icu nurse
so is her husband benjamin to sit there
and say
oh well they're just making it out to be
way worse than it is and it's not that
bad you know i wish we were making it up
you know i wish i wasn't holding the
hands of somebody as they're about to be
intubated while they look up at me and
say am i going to die
since the onset of delta variant cases
of covet 19 dr cormier has only had two
patients come off the ventilator and
survive
it's something kaylee rayo's family is
praying for
they've left a rosary in her hand and a
prayer blanket across her bed and in her
line of sight just in case she wakes up
are pictures of her family
the hardest part is leaving your
children or your adult child
fight this virus alone
she's the youngest covet patient in the
icu
and she's fighting for her life
over the weekend kaylee's lungs
collapsed the family was called to the
hospital they thought it was going to be
the end but dr cormier and his medical
team revived her and so she lives to
fight another day
before we left this hospital on friday
after spending nearly nine hours in the
icu the staff asked one thing of us
they said david please tell people
get vaccinated david thank you we can't
say that enough no we can't say that
enough said it over and over again story
you know it gave me goosebumps to hear
the doctors say she's not better but
she's not worse and you're holding on to
the not worst part and then you hear her
lungs collapse but she's still fighting
it's i don't know what more we can say
to people and i think it's important to
hear the nurses and the doctors say this
stuff is very very very important and to
hear people like david begner go down
there he's from lafayette yeah that town
yep yeah just devastating to see her she
just gave birth and she's lying there in
an icu emotionless